a story that spans decades and even
jumps around in time is bound to have a
few plot holes that could bring the
audience's enjoyment
to a screeching halt however when it
comes to the fast and furious franchise
those reality busting moments
might just be part of the charm in the
oft
forgotten too fast too furious brian
o'connor finds himself an outlaw living
in miami and doing
what he does best street racing the
person behind the miami underworld
street racing scene is mechanic and
organizer tej parker
when fans are first introduced to the
character he's a humble mechanic who
used to street race like brian
however after hitting a wall doing 120
miles per hour he doesn't drive anymore
instead he just organizes races tej then
disappears until fast five when he's
called to brazil to help brian and dom
toretto with a heist
that's where he also demonstrates a
renewed ability to drive
an intimate knowledge of high-tech safes
and the ability to acquire
almost anything in the world for their
odd little safe house in rio
by the fate of the furious he's also
demonstrated that he's an
expert martial artist and a hacker
that's capable of impressing ramsay who
multiple governments are seeking for her
technology tej goes from being a humble
mechanic
to a world-class criminal mastermind
hacker
driver fighter and acquisitions expert
at no point is the impressive expansion
of his skill set
adequately explained a brief attempt to
justify his skills was made in fast five
but tej simply said he had a life before
brian met him and too fast too furious
that actually muddies the waters further
implying he had these skills back then
and chose not to use them people can get
good at things over the course of their
lives but tej
is simply too good at too many things
in fast and furious 6 owen shaw is
introduced as the man that's been using
a team
similar to dom's family to conduct all
kinds of unseemly business around the
globe
furthermore he's recruited dom's old
childhood flame
letty taking advantage of the fact that
the attempt on her life in fast and
furious left her with no memory
by the end of the film owen is
responsible for the death of giselle
a member of dom's crew after defeating
owen deckard shaw comes out of the
woodwork to get revenge
he starts by assassinating han a
long-time member of dominic's crew
he doesn't stop there deckard blows up
dominic's los
angeles home which he shares with his
sister brian
and their son fortunately everyone makes
it out alive
shaw later attacks dom at han's funeral
and makes several other attempts on his
life before being captured and thrown in
jail
however one film later dom is backed
into a corner and has no choice but to
trust his old enemies with none other
than his
own baby despite straight up murdering
his close friends
stealing his girlfriend and trying to
kill his family
dom trusts the shaw brothers to not
betray him while they do his dirty work
once the mission is over he even
welcomes deckard to a
family barbecue in new york city
forgiveness
is a very complicated thing but this is
a bit
much the first movie opens with brian
o'connor taking his shot at becoming a
detective by going undercover in the
street racing world
the film ends with him befriending
dominic toretto and letting him escape
custody
just like that he goes on the run and
becomes a full-fledged criminal and
fugitive
he's eventually found by the fbi in
miami but instead of arresting him they
recruit him to do a job for them and
bust a worse criminal
he complies with the request leading to
his record being cleared
but it doesn't stop there the next time
the audience sees brian he's a full-on
fbi agent now someone with a clean
record can presumably go through the
steps to become an fbi agent
however given that the fbi are the ones
that cleared him in the first place
it's improbable to think that they
weren't aware of who he was
or his propensity for letting street
racer friends escape justice
it's almost like the feds get what's
coming to them when fast and furious
ends with brian
predictably offering to let dominic off
the hook only to have to orchestrate his
daring prison break weeks later
in the end brian ends up on the wrong
side of a wanted poster but he frankly
shouldn't have ever been trusted on the
right side in the first place
fate of the furious had the burden of
having to top the seven movies that came
before it
its attempt to do that can be summed up
in a daring scene in which dominic
toretto has to face off against his own
team in a new york city chase
dom however has the support of the
criminal mastermind cypher who has her
team of expert hackers
take over autonomous cars in the city
and remotely drive them like they're a
sea of
unfriendly metal cypher says i want
every chip with a zero day exploit in a
two mile radius around that motorcade
now hack them all to put it really
really simply a zero day exploit is
basically a bit of software that hackers
are able to
well hack on its own it doesn't come
anywhere
close to explaining how minivans and
older model sedans could get
hacked and driven like remote control
vehicles
simply put the impressive looking sea of
cars that cypher has her team manifest
to a dom
in stealing a nuclear football simply
cannot exist
not only would the gridlock in new york
city be too immense to get the cars past
a few miles per hour but the scene shows
her controlling cars that the audience
is led to believe
have both a cassette player and a
high-tech auto-driving chip
the big plot twist in fate of the
furious hinges on dominic's old lover
elena having secretly given birth to his
baby however
for those keeping track of the timeline
of events that
really doesn't add up elena is
introduced and develops a romantic
relationship with dominic in fast five
when we see her again in fast and
furious six she agrees to let dom go so
he can be with letting now that she's
alive
weird sure but it's her choice to help
move on with her life she joins lucas
hobbs at the diplomatic security
services
when we see her again in furious 7 she's
a full-fledged agent having clearly gone
through whatever presumably lengthy
process goes into making a local rio
police officer who ran off with a wanted
international
fugitive into a dss agent what's more
she doesn't seem to be showing a baby
bump
at all when deckard shaw explodes her
and hobbs out the window of a
very tall building fortunately that
death death-defying stunt had no
impact on her unborn child overall it
just doesn't really track that she would
have had a baby with dom
she would have had to conceive a child
experience the events of
three movies and get a new career off
the ground in a matter of weeks
she certainly wouldn't have been able to
hide it from hobbs who would have likely
told dom that he's got a love child out
there it's a pretty big plot hole for
something that will
seemingly inform a lot of the franchise
going forward
everyone meet brian
anyone who watched fast and furious 6
was likely struck by
two things during its climax the first
being the thrilling action
and the second being the fact that it
appeared to take place on a seemingly
endless runway for those who don't know
the climactic scene sees the bad guys
trying to escape in a plane with one of
the good guys
they're hostage dom's crew has to catch
up in their cars and
somehow find a way to ground the plane
and get their friend off before it takes
off
what ensues is a roughly 13 minute
action sequence that's truly unlike
anything that came before it
since the movie premiered in 2013 many
internet sleuths and
amateur mathematicians have done their
best to calculate
exactly how long the runway would have
to be in order to accommodate the
lengthy chase
the people at vulture factored in the
car's speeds and consulted an
actual pilot to tell them how fast a
cargo plane like that needs to go before
it can take off
and their estimate put the runway at
about 28.8 miles long
the folks at the bbc however factored in
the idea that the movie was cutting
between multiple things happening at
once
and put its estimate at 18.37 miles long
regardless they both agree that the
film's runway
well exceeds the largest paved runway in
the world which is around
3.5 miles fast and the furious reunited
the original gang from the first movie
and is in many ways the first direct
sequel to the original the fast and the
furious movie
the thing that brings brian o'connor and
dominic toretto back together is the
sudden and tragic death of their mutual
friend
letty when brian convinced letty to be
an informant to the fbi she got involved
with some bad runners
one of them phoenix betrayed her and
chased her down
he wrecked her car and is believed to
have put a bullet in her head
later in the movie he tells dom that he
doesn't remember leddy's face
he couldn't last time i saw it it was
burning
so apparently there was a fire in fast
and furious six brian goes to prison and
is sold by phoenix's boss that phoenix
actually pointed his gun at the gas tank
and blew up the car first of all a
bullet to the gas tank doesn't always
blow up the car in real life but that's
not the main issue
the main issue is him saying he
definitely killed letty and
even saw her body burning as fans know
letty was blown clear of the wreckage
no bullet wounds and definitely no burns
instead she just has a nasty case of
amnesia which explains why she doesn't
remember giselle bringing her to the
hospital where she was found and
recruited by owen shaw
fate of the furious begins with lucas
hobbs being approached by a fellow dss
agent to inform him that he needs to
recruit toreto's team for a job
retrieving an emp
he's told in no uncertain terms that
this operation in berlin
is off the books if he's caught he will
go to prison
and be completely disavowed by his
agency hobbes accepts
not knowing that toretto had been
approached by cipher and
blackmailed into betraying his team
hobbes is arrested
and sent to prison as promised however
despite committing a crime in berlin
and being disavowed by the dss he finds
himself in a dss prison
the same one that's housing deckard shaw
the question is
if the dss wanted to disavow hobbs for
getting pinched in berlin
why didn't they just let police in
berlin imprison him
how did he end up in the custody of the
people that are actively trying to
pretend that they have
nothing to do with him one could argue
that mr nobody orchestrated the whole
situation so he could bring
shaw into the mix however before hobbes
actually goes into his prison cell he's
approached by mr nobody with an offer to
work for him which he rejects
this makes the ensuing prison riot a
clear plan b
for mr nobody admittedly no true fan
of the franchise would sacrifice the
prison riot scene in that movie for all
the international prisoner exchange
logistics in the world
however the fact remains that it's a big
plot hole
at the conclusion of furious 7 letty
reveals that at some point during the
movie she got the entirety of her memory
back
just in time for the news to somehow
heal dom's wounds and bring him back to
consciousness
by the eighth movie she's back to the
character we saw last in
fast and furious however it's not fully
explained how
letty got her memory back or why in the
world she decided to sit on that
information until dom was basically
dead it's very subtly implied earlier in
the film that her fight with kara in abu
dhabi
may have knocked something loose in her
brain sadly it's
never fully explained and it doesn't
look like the remainder of the franchise
has
any plans to backtrack to address that
instead odds are good they'll forge
ahead with even more reality bending
over the top action movie insanity
not that anyone's complaining about that
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the fast and furious movies are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you